le festival béryl est 5ème édition c'est
tout ce week-end à châteauroux un
festival sans chichi on nous dit berry
l'est le berry on se trouve en son coeur
mais pourquoi l'est on est là dans une
ancienne coopérative laitière qui a
nourri les petits castelroussin pendant
de nombreuses années avec du lait
pasteurisé ou des yaourts mais pour
continuer à nourrir les petits et
castelroussin avec avec ce magma
culturelle qu'on essaye de proposer sur
des scènes vivantes actuelle cette année
c'est le quintette angevins gillet et
pauline croze qui sont les têtes
d'affiché mais comment ils font à berry
l'est pour attirer le gratin de la
chanson française
mais j'ai vite arrêté
nos amis technicien qui qui tourne pas
mal sûr sur les spectacles font
l'intermédiaire en général vous savez
c'est un petit monde donc léger beaucoup
de techniciens se connaissent donc tu
aurais pas une adresse tient que tu
penses de telles salles ou autre et on
commence à voir une petite réputation
d'un endroit chaleureux convivial où ils
peuvent s'exprimer dans de très bonnes
conditions et dans la constellation de
concert il ya celui de l'incontournable
grégory jolivet l'un des meilleurs
joueur de vielle à roue d'europe
il nous la livre à écouter dans sa
version électro
[Musique]
c'est interplanétaire c'est une espèce
est un spectacle qui est étonnant une
vielle dont on al c'était cet a priori
d'un instrument traditionnel qui
aujourd'hui ressemble à une guitare
électrique un violoncelle un accordéon
j'ai pas de qualificatifs pour décrire
ce son particulier cette ambiance
particulière
on va le laisser s'exprimer il est en
solo ça va être un dimanche après midi
assez explosif de châteauroux nous fit
non plus au nord au musée saint roch
d'issoudun où nous avons interpellé le
conservateur sur ce tableau les élus
d'inspiration religieuse il a été
réalisé en 1986 par le peintre algérien
abdallah b nanterre récemment disparu il
a une culture en fait très générale
religieuse inspiré autant par le
soufisme qui est ce syncrétisme un petit
peu toutes les religions donc aussi par
la connaissance que le bouddhisme du
christianisme évidemment et en fait ce
qu'il impressionne énormément si
notamment les grands retables de la
renaissance du moyen âge surtout celui
de design donc il ya cet aspect
religieux qui en référence à l'histoire
de l'art à l'histoire de la peinture
effectivement tous ces petits
personnages qui sont des silhouettes à
peine
on devine des silhouettes blanches qui
sont effectivement à l'évocation des
âmes et qui s'élève qui montrent qu'ils
sont comme souffler un petit peu par du
bas de du sol de la terre et on sent
quelque chose de très aérien très
volatil et un petit peu comme une
envolée de papillons qui se parsème sur
toute la toile
musique au bled entre montoir et vendôme
la petite commune de thoré la rochette
accueille ce samedi soir la 10e édition
déjà de gare à la rochette
une fête populaire sur le site de
l'ancienne gare pour une soirée de
concerts gratis si si on a retenu celui
des black bones et leur pop rock
inventive avec ce morceau
ilike do it chaud chaud le rythme dans
la peau le groupe holy fans est de la
partie au festival jeune public bricka
note toute la journée de dimanche à
saint-avertin les enfants vont pouvoir
se trémousser devant de la chanson
gesticuler et du théâtre de papier c'est
à partir de 10 heures
bon week-end à tous